You, uh,
you're the co-founder of just like we've been talking about axial systems. Uh,
would you say space propulsion company? Yes. Broadly speaking. Um,
so, uh, how do you, big question, how do you, uh,
build a rocket company from like a
propulsion company from one person from two people to 10
people plus, and actually, you know,
take it to a successful product?
Yeah, well, I think the early stage is quite, uh,
I'm not supposed to use the word easy when you work in rocket science,
but straightforward. Um, when you're working on something, you know,
sexy like an ion engine,
it's more straightforward to raise money and get people to come work for
you because the vision is really exciting.
And actually that's something I would say is very important throughout is,
um,
a really exciting vision because when everything goes to crap,
um, you need that to get people getting themselves out of bed in the morning and
thinking of the, the higher purpose there. Um, and you know,
another thing along the way that I think is key and in building any
company is, um,
the right early employees that also have their own networks and
can bring in, um, a lot of people that, um,
you know, really make the, this the whole greater than,
than just the, some of the early team.
And how do you build that? Like how do you find people it's like asking,
like how do you make friends, but is there, um, is it a,
is it luck? Is there a system like how,
in terms of the people you've connected with the, the people, um,
you built the company with,
is there some thread, some commonality, some pattern, the,
find it to be, to hold for what makes a great team?
Uh, I think, you know, personally, uh,
a thread for me has been my network and
being able to draw on that a lot,
but also giving back to it as much as possible and like an
unsolicited sort of way, like making connections between people that,
you know, maybe didn't ask, but that, um, I think could be really fruitful and,
um, even weirder than that is just really
getting, you know, having weird,
uncomfortable conversations with people like at a conference and getting
over the small talk quickly and getting to know them quickly and having a
relationship that stands out and then being able to call on them later because
that, um, and I think that's, it's,
that's been because I'm introverted and I, you know,
want to poke my eyes out instead of go and do small talk.
And so I huddle in a corner with one person and, you know,
we talk about aliens or things like that. And, um, so, you know,
that's all to say that, you know,
having a strong network I think is really important, but a genuine one.
And let's see other ways to build a rocket company kind of making sure you're
paying attention to this sweeping trends of the industry.
So everybody just cares about cost and, um,
being able to get out ahead of that.
And even more than we ever thought we need to,
as far as what we needed to price our systems that, you know,
people for since the start of the
U S space industry, they've been paying 20,
25 million in adjusted dollars for an eye on in gen.
And seeing that now people are going to want to pay
10 K for an ion engine, um,
and just staying out ahead of that and those kinds of things. Um, so, you know,
being out in the industry and talking to as many people.
So there's a drive. I mean, I suppose space X really pushed that for me.
So a space X really pushed this, uh, yeah,
the application of, uh, I guess, capitalism of driving the price down of, um,
basically forcing people to ask the question, can this,
can this be done cheaper? Um, th this can lead to
like big problems, I would say in the following sense,
I see this in the car industry, for example, that, uh,
people have S it's such a small margin for
profit.
Like they've driven the cost of everything down so much that there's literally
no room for innovation for taking risks. So like cars,
which is funny because not until Tesla really,
which is one of the, in a long, long time,
one of the first successful new car companies,
that's constantly innovating.
Every other car company is really pouring in terms of their technological
innovation. They innovate on design and style. And so on that you,
that people fall in love with the look and so on,
but it's not really innovation, the insurance of the technology,
and it's really boringly the same thing and they have really afraid of taking
risks. And that's a big problem for RocketSpace too, is like,
if you're cutting on costs, you can't afford to innovate to try out new things.
And that's definitely true with ion engine. Right. Uh,
so, but what, um, so how do you compete in this, uh,
in this space, do you, by the way, see space X as a competitor, uh,
and what do you say in general about the competition in this space?
Is it really difficult as a, as a business to compete here?
No, I, I don't see space X as a competitor. Um,
and I see them as one day, not too long from now a customer,
hopefully. Um, I mean, to compete against that,
I think you just have to do things in an unconventional way.
So bringing Silicon memes, manufacturing to propulsion,
you know,
NASA doesn't make ion engines using a batch
mass producible technique. They have, you know,
one guy that's been making their eye on engines for 20 years,
like bespoke pieces of jewelry. So, um,
bringing things to what you're trying to innovate to make
them, you know, in our case more cost-effective was, was really key.
Well, I liked the idea of somebody putting out I on engines on like Etsy.
Yeah. My, um, advisor at MIT would, you know,
the thruster chip I was holding up, he would wear one as a lapel pin.